[Musik]
er ist klar wie wasser riecht kaum passt
ohne umbau in jedem dieseltank und in
jedes flugzeug synthetischer kraftstoffe
ein wundermittel aus dem labor volle
leistung auch auf der rennstrecke dabei
effizienter und sauberer ist zum tee
tischer sprit die lösung in der diesel
krise macht ihr die wende auf der straße
möglich bald sollen millionen liter
produziert werden
hergestellt aus nichts weiter als wasser
und co2
aber lohnt sich der sache
es ist der teuerste weg und co2 im pkw
bereich zu vermeiden
[Musik]
der geländeparcours in gaggenau in baden
württemberg ist nichts für normale autos
hier braucht man spezial fahrwerk und
ordentlich power
normalerweise werden besuchern hier ps
strotzende boliden vorgeführt diesmal
allerdings ist alles anders
unimog profi daniel müller fühlt
synthetischen kraftstoff in den tank das
aus pflanzlichen fetten hergestellt
hv er will wissen bringt der neue sprit
die gleiche kraft wie diese heute ein
extremes hat es normal tank der diesel
und probieren jetzt einfach mal aus
geschenkt wird dem unimog auf dem
parcours nichts gucken hindernisse auch
schräglagen von 20 grad muss erschaffen
bisher läuft es auch mit den neuen
kraftstoff rund der dickste brocken
steht müllers gelände brummi aber noch
bevor diese rampe mit einer steigung von
100% künstliche kraftstoffe ganz ohne
erdöl
das prinzip ist eigentlich lange bekannt
gegen diese und benzin haben
synthetische kraftstoffe auch sinn fuels
genannt bisher dennoch keine chance in
deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
in stuttgart wird geforscht um genau das
zu ändern
gesucht der optimale kraftstoff der
zukunft dass der nur synthetisch sein
kann steht für professor aigner und sein
team außer frage
um zu zeigen warum zerlegen sie die
kraftstoffe in ihre bestandteile links
kerosin aus erdöl eher ungeordnet rechts
das sinnvoll
eine gerade linie aus wenigen
kohlenwasserstoff molekülen vielleicht
sogar tausende jedes hat seine
eigenschaften 1 ist unvorteilhaft mainz
ist nach berga und beim sensation
kraftstoff werden wir vielleicht in zehn
zwanzig minuten haben vielleicht sogar
nur 2 wir können diese moleküle ebenso
aussuchen das die eigenschaften
überwiegend vorteilhaft sind
so werden zum beispiel aromatische
moleküle die ruß und damit feinstaub
erzeugen einfach weggelassen
der treibstoff wird designt dabei ist
den forschern erst einmal egal wo hier
die gewünschten moleküle ursprünglich
kommen ob aus fetten oder bio abfällen
aus erdgas oder auch aus wasser und co2
die technik überformt kein neuer jetzt
zerlegen die quelle in ganz kleine
moleküle wegen energie dazu und bauen
daraus dann eingekracht auf und der
crafter später weiß nicht mehr wo er
herkam
viel wichtiger ist den forschern wie
effizient ist er und wie sauber den
unterschied zeigt ein einfache versuche
die linke flamme brennt mit kerosin die
rechte mit einem sinn für das ergebnis
ist sichtbar und messbar
grün heißt roos und feinstaub bei
kerosin ist die linie dick beim
synthetischen kraftstoff kaum noch zu
erkennen
das ist abhängig vom kraftstoff der
schwabe abhängig von der anwendung die
man machen um einen motor im flug
triebwerk oder im haushaltsplan alles
verwenden
aber beides kann man davon ausgehen dass
man den artikel und damit auch den
feinstaub etwa halbiert das kann man
relativ gut erreichen und das bild auch
recht generell für viele anwendungen ist
der neue sprit eine lösung für die dicke
luft in deutschen städten neben
feinstaub sind dort stickoxide kurz nx
ein problem
beide schadstoffe kommen auch aus dem
diesel auspuff die belastung ist zwar
insgesamt rückläufig 2017 wurden die nx
grenzwerte aber immer noch in mehr als
60 deutschen städten überschritten
gerichte verhängen deshalb vielerorts
fahrverbote in deutschland sind mehr als
15 millionen diesel pkw zugelassen
weniger als ein drittel davon erfüllen
die aktuelle schadstoffnorm euro 6
können sie uns auch den stickoxid
ausstoß reduzieren
ja glaubt professor heinzl von der
hochschule für technik und wirtschaft in
saarbrücken stickoxide entstehen bei
verbrennungen
je heißer desto mehr nx was aber
passiert mit den werten wenn statt
diesel synthetischer kraftstoffe in den
tank gefüllt wird
professor heinze will das herausfinden
dazu baut sein team stickoxid sensoren
in die abgassysteme von vier testautos 1
erfasst werden zusätzlich daten aus der
motorsteuerung zum beispiel über den
verbrauch und damit können wir dann
letztendlich ein sehr aufwendiges
professor system installieren müssen
die methode ist zuverlässig das haben
tests vergleiche mit den messungen
großer anlagen ergeben
zwei wochen lang werden vier dienstautos
einer getränkefirma abwechselnd mit
normalem diesel und synthetischem
kraftstoff fahren auch hier mit den
pflanzlichen hv
kein versuch im labor sondern ein echter
einsatz auf der straße
den forschern ist klar die ergebnisse
entscheiden mit darüber welche zukunft
sinn fuels haben werden
[Musik]
zuviel nx und feinstaub gerade in helfen
ein problem
dort sind die werte oft viel höher als
in der innenstadt wegen deutlich laxer
anforderungen an schiffe die stadt
hamburg will das ändern
zumindest bei der eigenen flotte fast
alle ihre schiffe bunkern deshalb statt
diesel gtl einen anderen synthetischen
kraftstoff die aus erdgas molekülen
hergestellt wird
carsten schönewald chef der flotte
hamburg geht an bord des schleppers und
eisbrechers johannes dalmann schönewald
weiß dass viele schiffsführer skeptisch
sind
kann das mit dem neuen kraftstoff
wirklich klappen dass die schiffe
sauberer sind hat sich immerhin
herumgesprochen
ein wissenschaftlicher test mit einer
barkasse hat das gezeigt dass wir
wirklich messwerte haben vergleich
vorher nachher unbestechliche zahlen und
dabei kam raus dass wir im mittelwert
die partikel masse sprich feinstaub um
etwa 50 prozent reduzieren konnten mit
gtl und stickoxide waren über zehn
reduziert es geht zum bunkern also zum
betanken mit gtl die johannes dalmann
hat zwei tanks in jedem von ihnen passen
mehr als 10.000 liter dass es nun nicht
mehr nach diesel stinkt dass es beim
starken keine dicke rußwolke gibt hat
die mannschaft schnell mitbekommen was
aber ist mit der motorleistung im winter
fand sie es heraus
die leistung hat er voll und ganz immer
gebracht eigentlich erstaunlich selbst
damit gerechnet habe dass er
irgendwelche einbußen hat so das eis
gegangen hat alles wirklich gemerkt was
wir zu knacken geben wir waren
überrascht dass das alles so super
klappt mit dem die flotte hamburg
verwendet mit gtl den synthetischen
kraftstoff der bisher am weitesten
verbreitet ist
im vergleich mit diesel ist der
verbrauch in deutschland noch
verschwindend gering
doch die tendenz steigt die herstellung
von gtl hat einen nachteil
erdgas ist kein erneuerbarer rohstoff
verglichen mit anderen quellen ist die
co2 bilanz eher schlecht
bei feinstaub und nx dagegen sind die
wirte gut die flotte hamburg will
deshalb bald alle 50 schiffe umstellen
auch wenn das mehr kostet
wir machen das auch im hamburger hafen
hat das beispiel bereits nachahmer
gefunden
auch einige betreiber von
ausflugsschiffen sind aufs in fuel
umgestiegen
aber ist das schadstoff problem so in
den griff zu bekommen
auch auf der straße zwei wochen lang
waren die vier -test autos unterwegs
sensoren haben den stickoxidausstoß
gemessen und die daten an das team von
professor heinz nach saarbrücken gefunkt
und tatsächlich der stickoxidausstoß ist
im vergleich zu normalem diesel um rund
11 prozent niedriger
heinze glaubt dass das mit der reinheit
synthetischer kraftstoffe zu tun hat
es gibt halt keine besonderen
verzögerungen in der verbrennung die
dann eventuell zu ruse führen noch züge
führen sondern wir haben es mit einer
sehr robusten verbrennung zu tun
auch die man sich eben einstellen kann
so dass daneben schadstoffarm
durchfahren können für die
wissenschaftler in saarbrücken ein
erstes vielversprechendes ergebnis
professor einzel geht aber davon aus
dass bei der entwicklung noch viel luft
nach oben ist ist es möglich
wir sind jetzt nicht mehr angewiesen das
zu nehmen was aus der erde kommt sondern
können von vornherein ein augenmerk auf
wegen dass wir kraftstoffe haben die für
unser verbrennungsmotoren optimal
bezüglich wirkungsgrad und bezüglich
start-stopp-funktion optimale
kraftstoffe in optimalen motoren eine
vision die bald realität werden könnte
für normale autos aber nicht nur für die
[Musik]
der hockenheimring üblicherweise kein
ort an dem viel über schadstoffe
nachgedacht wird dafür umso mehr über
tempo und leistung beim track day dürfen
privatleute mit ihren schnellen wagen
auf die piste aber auch profis testen
ihre autos
[Musik]
so wie der bayerische rennstall tuning
akademie 420 ps hat ihr audi rs5 biturbo
für die fahrt auf dem ring hat das team
viel verändert vor allem an
motorsteuerung brems kühlung und
aerodynamik
immerhin 2017 war es mit dem auto
klassen dritter beim 24 stunden rennen
auf dem nürburgring und das mit
synthetischem kraftstoff im tank
teamchef thomas hanisch will nun wissen
ist dann auch mehr aus dem wagen heraus
zu holen
[Musik]
auf der strecke liegt der audi gut keine
probleme in den kurven und 280 sachen
sind mühelos drin das harnisch mit
sinnvoll im tank ein renn exot ist merkt
hier niemand auch nicht dass der wagen
mit sensoren vollgestopfte ist
sie zeichnen so gut wie alles auf was
technisch während des rennens passiert
das macht ihn für die branche zum
optimalen objekt um neue komponenten im
rennbetrieb zu testen und neue
kraftstoffe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der rs5 kehrt in die box zurück
alles ist heil geblieben unfälle bleiben
auch bei testfahrten nicht immer aus
jetzt werden die daten ausgelesen die
veränderungen an bremsen und aerodynamik
haben sich gelohnt
gilt das auch für das neue motor mapping
denn das ist auf den synthetischen
kraftstoff abgestimmt
wir versuchen natürlich über eine
weitere applikation diesen kraftstoff
noch besser zu nutzen dementsprechend
auch die verbrennungstemperaturen zur
reduzierung der komponenten einem
höheren betriebspunkt betreiben zu
können aber die erfahrung ist mit dem
kraftstoff sind sehr sehr gut wir haben
die gleiche leistung wir haben etwas
mehr drehmoment und wir haben
ich glaube um 40 prozent weniger aus
und tatsächlich der test zeigt der wagen
ist durch die veränderungen schneller
geworden für harnisch und das team eine
einfache rechnung werden kraftstoff und
motor gut aufeinander abgestimmt dann
sind mehr leistung und tempo drin mehr
sinn fuels auch im rennsport für die
tuning akademie spricht nichts dagegen
vorausgesetzt die kraftstoffe sind auch
zu bekommen
das team kaufte sie in tanks und fässern
im alltag von autofahrern ist das
allerdings unrealistisch
für benziner wird sinnvoll noch gar
nicht angeboten synthetischen diese gibt
es bisher nur an einer hand voll
tankstellen in deutschland taxi
unternehmer norbert schöpfel hat durch
zufall eine im baden-württembergischen
öhringen gefunden
er will etwas für die umwelt tun ohne
seine taxis umzubauen oder durch e autos
zu ersetzen
das synthetische hv das hier care diesel
genannt wird kann er tue tanten oder mit
normalem diesel mission schöpfe ist
stammkunde zunächst inseln auch kunden
die was für die energiewende tun wollen
die klimaneutral tanken wollen
aber es gibt immer mehr kunden die auch
die produktvorteile sehen also dass ein
beispiel wenn sie heute mit einem
rußfilter fahrzeug viel kitsch trecker
fahren dann haben sie oft das problem
dass der ruß viel dafür bloggt oder
zugeht und sie müssen dann regenerieren
auf die autobahn vollgasfahrt und in die
werkstatt wir haben viele kunden die das
produkt handlungen des problems komplett
erledigt landwirte gehören zu seinen
kunden auch die örtliche feuerwehr
taxiunternehmer schöpfel hat außerdem
festgestellt dass der neue sprit im
winter mit der kälte besser klarkommt
das fahrzeug hatte im kaltstart die erst
ein paar minuten ziemlich die klopften
genagelt und erst dann wenn die sklaven
wurde war es ruhig und mit dem kerl
diesel war es sofort im teilstaat auch
ruhig der motor ruhig gelaufen
eine anderes fahrzeug das ich gezeigt
habe im kaltstart ohne vortrieb sofort
angesprungen bei minus zehn grad
erfahrungen für die sich
tankstellenbetreiber weissert sehr
interessiert er weiß viele autofahrer
sind skeptisch sie haben angst vor
schäden
denn bisher haben nur wenige autobauer
ha vu für ihre motoren offiziell
freigegeben
die hersteller sagen auch die feigen die
pkw-hersteller wieso sollen wir ein
produkt freigebe sie müssen das ja frei
messe stehen danach auch für die
abgaswerte wenn das produkt auf dem
markt eigentlich gar nicht verfügbar ist
also deswegen machen sie sich die mühe
nicht
und tatsächlich ist die ahv anteil auf
dem deutschen kraftstoffmarkt noch klein
für 2017 wird er auf nur 0
0,3 prozent geschätzt
[Musik]
doch wann sind die sind juhls reif für
den großen sprung
die forscher am dlr wollen den optimalen
kraftstoff schon in wenigen jahren
finden
dazu sammeln sie riesige datenmengen für
computer modelle wie verdunsten die
verschiedenen treibstoffe wie zünden und
verbrennen sie hier wird ihr verhalten
in motoren und triebwerken simuliert
wenn wir die modelle haben wenn wir
voraus haben wenn wir ein bestimmter
kraftstoff sich verhält der kümmert den
ice auch verändern
wir können dann im ziel bestimmte
moleküle aus nehmen oder irgendwie an
eine konstellation verändern und können
dann im computer testen ob damit mehr
russ wie viel mehr rosen steht oder auch
die zündung einfacher wird oder die
lagerfähigkeit besser wird es folgt die
seine arbeit am computer eine
herausforderung ist vor allem die
luftfahrt hier schadstoffe zu reduzieren
ist schwierig flugzeuge brauchen große
mengen kerosin sie komplett auf sinnvoll
umzustellen ist wegen der kosten und der
begrenzten verfügbarkeit noch
unrealistisch aber hilft vielleicht die
richtige mischung das hat das dlr
zusammen mit der nasa im januar 2018 in
ramstein getestet im tank des airbus a
320 ein mix der zu 30 prozent aus
synthetischem kerosin besteht
der treibstoff wurde am computer designt
und perfekt auf die maschine abgestimmt
im modell konnte damit der
feinstaubausstoß halbiert werden
ein messflugzeug der nasa fliegt hinter
dem airbus hier
und tatsächlich die daten bestätigen die
berechnungen ein erfolg für die
dlr-forscher und vielleicht eine
perspektive für die verkehrswende in der
luft denn dort sind alternative antriebe
technisch noch nicht vorstellbar es war
kein flugzeug geben dass 100 oder 200
passagiere befördert wird aber weder
airbus 380 über 500 passagiere und über
den teich fliegt ohne verbindungssystem
das wird es nicht geben
synthetische kraftstoffe auf basis von
fetten und erdgas sind für flugzeuge
weltweit freigegeben
manche airlines mischen sie den kerosin
bereits bei die regel ist das allerdings
noch nicht
ebenso wenig wie am boden mit
synthetischen sprit im tank kämpft sich
daniel müller in gaggenau weiter durch
den geländeparcours es läuft bisher
trotzdem kann sich müller nicht sicher
sein
der motor ist für diese gebaut und der
unimog muss mehr leisten als normale
autos die steigung mit 100 prozent rückt
näher und an der sind schon viele
gescheitert
[Musik]
in fuel ihre ökobilanz ist besser als
bei sprit aus erdöl
optimal ist sie aber noch nicht wenn
fossiles erdgas der rohstoff ist oder
pflanzen die anbaufläche brauchen in
dresden setzt man deshalb auf eine
komplett nachhaltige lösung
hier steht die pilotanlage der firma sun
fire
sie kann täglich etwa 160 liter eines
synthetischen rohöl ersatzes produzieren
die zutaten ausschließlich co2 wasser
und ökostrom letztlich es ist ja erst
mal nichts anderes als das was die natur
macht die natur macht über photosynthese
aus co2 und wasser mit sonnenlicht eine
pflanze und über jahren millionen von
jahren wird diese pflanze zu erdöl das
heißt die ausgangsstoffe sind eigentlich
erstmal genau die gleichen
wir machen das ganze nur mit einem
verfahren im chemischen labor wenn man
so möchte wenn man das ja als labor
bezeichnen möchte
das verfahren nennt sich pcl und es
funktioniert inzwischen so gut dass sein
vater in norwegen jetzt eine
produktionsanlage bauen will mit einer
kapazität von 10 millionen litern im
jahr
firmenmitgründer nils aldag berät sich
deshalb mit ingenieur karl hauptmeier
das problem noch ist die herstellung
ineffizient und zu teuer wenn damit
einmal geld verdient werden soll muss
sich etwas ändern
wir sind aber heute an einem punkt
angelangt wo erneuerbare energie aus
wind und sonne günstiger ist als die
jetzt als die energie aus fossilen
energieträgern
das heißt je günstiger sonne und wind
werden desto günstiger wird auch unser
produkt und das ist so ein desto näher
kommen wir an ein szenario der endkunde
bereit ist tatsächlich für diesen
erneuerbaren kraftstoff zu zahlen
norwegen bietet sich an weil hier der
strom vor allem aus wasserkraft kommt er
ist damit zu fast 100 prozent erneuerbar
und vergleichsweise billig
wir wollen in dem norwegen projekt
zeigen dass das funktioniert und dass
man eben nicht nur kraftstoffe für pkw
oder lkw produzieren kann sondern auch
kraftstoffe für die luftfahrt
wenn es gut geht sind noch größere
anlagen geplant an orten wo es günstigen
ökostrom gibt zb auch in der wüste
alltag und seine mitarbeiter haben dafür
bereits möglichkeiten gefunden um die
produktion deutlich zu vereinfachen
ein nächster schritt statt wie bisher
co2 einzukaufen wollen sie es direkt aus
der luft holen muss sich das so
vorstellen dass die luft gefiltert wird
das co2 werten entfernt und unseren
prozess dann wieder zur verfügung
gestellt wir waren dieses co2 wieder an
ein kraftstoff welches dann am ende
seines lebens wieder in die luft
sozusagen abblasen wird und womit der
einen absoluten kreislauf geschaffen
haben das co2 wird durch kein zug einer
anreicherung gekommen
das ptl mit anderen kraftstoffen
konkurrieren kann ist für hauptmeier und
alltag nur eine frage der zeit und des
politischen willens
positive signale kommen aus der eu und
von der bundesregierung beide wollen die
entwicklungen voranbringen
eine große bremse sind bei allen sinn
fuels bisher die hohen kosten noch ist
der aufwand groß und der absatz gering
in öhringen zahlt taxiunternehmer
schöpfel deshalb für den liter half auch
mal 30 cent mehr als für normale denn
die wird einkassiert auch wenn ha vu gar
nicht aus öl hergestellt wird
hohe kosten und begrenzten ressourcen
haben dies in fuels bei der
verkehrswende überhaupt eine chance oder
sollten sich forscher und hersteller
nicht besser auf andere lösungen
konzentrieren
auf einer konferenz des thinktanks agora
verkehrswende in berlin wird auch über
diese fragen diskutiert es geht hier um
die zukunft der innenstädte
das hohe verkehrsaufkommen die belastung
durch schadstoffe sind synthetische
kraftstoffe eine lösung nein glaubt
christian hochfeld von agora aus seiner
sicht ergeben sind fuels für flugzeuge
oder schiffe zwar sinn für pkw aber
seien sie eine mogelpackung wollen wie
sie es gewohnt sind
denn für pflanzliche treibstoffe für den
großen markt müssten riesige
anbauflächen geschaffen werden in
konkurrenz zur nahrungsproduktion schon
jetzt werde für palmöl viel urwald
abgeholzt und es sei deutlich
effizienter mit ökostrom autos direkt
anzutreiben
als damit sind fuels zu produzieren es
wird auch der kunde am ende merken mitte
des nächsten jahrzehnts werden bei der
elektrischen fahrzeuge billiger werden
günstiger werden aus sicht des kunden
aus sicht des verbrauchers als
verbrenner fahrzeuge mit synthetischen
kraftstoffen power to liquid power to
gas ist der teuerste weg um co2 im pkw
bereich zu vermeiden hochfeld ist
überzeugt die probleme der e autos seien
leichter zu lösen als die der sintflut
forscher wie professor aigner sehen das
anders
auch bio abfälle können für die
herstellung verwendet werden er setzt
auf ein nebeneinander von batterie und
neuen kraftstoff auch auf der straße
immer dann wenn es um weite strecken
geht sei der verbrennungsmotor
unverzichtbar verbrennungsmotoren
betreiben wir dann auch tun ist mit
synthetischen co2 frei kraftstoffen die
auch wenig rußpartikel oder gar keine
rußpartikel mehr produzieren aber den
mix werden bestimmen bekommen
die frage ist nur wie viel prozent wird
welcher anteil seien neue verfahren und
quellen massenproduktion dabei steigende
ölpreise für aigner ist der siegeszug
des impuls nur eine frage der zeit
der kraftstoff der heute in heute
motoren einsetzen er halbiert die
schadstoffe aber macht sie nicht zu
holen
wir werden dann den optimalen motor die
optimale brennkammer von grünberg für
diesen optimalen kraftstoff entwickeln
und wenn die beiden relativ beiden
entwicklungen dank mal zu null
schadstoffe 0 schadstoffe volle leistung
gelände spezialist müller kann mit
solchen aussichten leben sein unimog
lässt sich nicht ausbremsen
auch nicht von der 100 prozent steigung
er schafft sie mühelos und das mit st
dass auch schwere gelände promis wie
sein unimog bald nur noch synthetischen
kraftstoff tanken für müller kein
problem
vor allem dann nicht wenn der sprit
verfügbar ist und der preis stimmt
[Musik]